what's up everybody welcome back welcome
back to the show
saturday at 1206 Pacific Standard Time I
hope everyone's doing okay staying safe
and being healthy I'm ready to jump into
this things is gonna be exciting we're
gonna be doing some fun modeling doing
some game assets this specifically we'll
be doing like the paraglider from
fortnight I think it's a fun pretty
basic model it may look a little
complicated at first but it's gonna be a
pretty simple process and I just want to
show you guys you know a lot of the
things I learned along the way
and I'll actually start with with a
little story here so while everyone's
getting into the chat I am gonna open up
YouTube and pull up an old video let's
see
all right so this is uh Killzone
extraction so a video I did in 2011 it's
about nine years ago holy crap and I
that's let's mute this here so you know
this video had a lot of the effects I'm
a big fan of the Killzone franchise more
so back you know back around this time
in 2011 and yeah there's a lot of VFX
going on in this video wait we got
really lucky we're able to film in this
textile mill in Thomaston Georgia and I
think they shot some of the The Hunger
Games or or one of those kind of movies
at this location years and years later
so during so that actually it's pretty
cool you can see this like robot flying
by it's super blurry this thing here but
more specifically I want to show you
guys this model here let's see if I
scrub forward here we go
okay so this right here there's a moment
where a drop ship crashes it's like it's
there it's there way out of here right
this drop ship crashes and blows up into
the you know side of the building here
and I had no idea how to model something
like this it's actually it looks pretty
complicated there's a lot of parts going
into this and I was completely stumped
and the only way I knew how to get
something like this was to reach out to
somebody else who was the best person I
knew for the job and that was Ian Hubert
and I I'm sure a lot of you guys know
Ian's work he's incredible and he
totally excels at this stuff and I mean
I'm he basically did this at his sleep I
mean I asked for his help one day the
next day he comes back with this thing
basically modeled the following day it's
completely modeled and the texturing is
almost done
by day three it just it's perfect it
looks like this
it's fantastic and it's exactly what I
needed to bring this thing together I
think he even tracked the shot to I
can't remember but yeah
shout out to Ian Hubert for helping me
out with this and because I didn't know
how to do this it was too complicated
for me but you know after years and
years of practicing and getting better
at 3d I realized that you know stuff
like that the very intricate mechanical
stuff like that is actually super super
doable and I want to show you guys how
to do that and again we'll be we'll be
doing a fortnight glider here this is a
kind of like a smaller version of that
drop ship but you guys get an idea and I
just want to share all my time-saving
tips with you guys and build this from
the ground up Eric thank you so much I
appreciate the super chat and by the way
guys last week with the whole frog jump
thing with the super chest yeah my legs
are still sore right now I was in so
much pain I basically have been running
three times a week
for probably two and a half months up
and to up until that point last week and
I
I ran nine miles the next day okay and
then after that I was done I couldn't I
could barely walk I needed help to stand
up so yeah I mean have to put a pause on
the frog jumps for a minute here and at
least until my legs are back to 100% cuz
man they still hurt but um yeah Eric
thank you so much for the super chat and
thank you for the support this is uh
this is awesome and I'm glad that I can
do this for you guys it's fun for me
it's fun for you hopefully and we all
get to learn stuff and no Ian Ian Hebert
does not work at corridor he is doing
his own thing we just thought a little
collaboration with him for that Willy
Wonka video
so in terms of programs and everything
you can use anything for this you can
use blender Maya 3ds max cinema 4d it
can literally be anything
these tips are universal you know you
should be able to take everything that
we're talking about here and use them on
your own program its basic its basic
just modeling you know when it comes
down to it it's basic modeling so I just
want to show you guys how you can take
basic modeling and build it up to
something more complicated like you know
like this or in Ian's case that dropship
that kills um dropship okay so I'm just
gonna hop into things here if everyone's
ready to go you'll do a little thumbs up
here and we will start the modeling
process I hope everyone's good I'm ready
to learn
gredin
that's a pretty sweet name yeah the
effects is all about problem-solving
that's that's basically it it's gonna
take you longer when you don't know how
to do something but you're gonna learn
how to do it through problem-solving and
eventually you will get what you're
going for there's a lot of that at
corridor a whole lot of that and then
you'll have to do it again
and this time you'll be a lot faster at
it and the more you do it the faster you
get and the more proficient you are and
with programs like this you know or any
3d software or 2d software like After
Effects or Photoshop whatever you just
need to use it enough so that you don't
forget those things you know all right
let's hop in I got thumbs up let's go
let's get rid of this sphere here and
yes I'm in s22 I'm loving it so far and
I got octane 2020 going I'm not gonna
use octane today I don't think maybe
we'll boot it up later but we're talking
about modeling today so all right how do
we begin what's the first thing yeah
there's there's a whole bunch of
different ways to go about making this
I'm just seeing a lot of cubes here you
know we're seeing wings the first thing
that all the all note here is it is
symmetrical so that's actually a huge a
huge thing for us as far as time saving
we only need a model half of this thing
because it is symmetrical so that's
probably the first thing I'm going to
set up here we'll start with some scale
so I know that if I spawn a figure the
figure I move this window here is 180
centimeters tall and that is generally
you know the height of an average person
here so if they type in 6 feet it's just
under 6 feet so I always spawn a figure
like that just to know how big
my scene is and kind of what I'm dealing
with here so I think the first thing
I'll do here is draw some guidelines I
think from the top so let's go into top
view and let's let's grab the spline
tool here and I'm just gonna turn on
snapping and workplane snapping as well
as what looks like it does it all now
okay great
that's fantastic okay so we're probably
looking at something like here to here
something like that I think it comes out
a little wider so I'm modeling this this
half right here okay and this is going
to just be a guide for us it looks like
it comes back to here
something uh something like that roughly
all right so I'm basically just gonna
build this up with a bunch of different
cubes and stuff I'll start with this
this like this you piece of metal right
here and it looks like there's a
cylinder connecting things in the back
so I'll start with this piece build out
this piece you got this piece on the
side here and then you have the wing so
I'll start with this main section we're
gonna build out this wing and then we
might get into some of this
cross-sections stuff then we can deal
with the pipes down here and then we can
get into the more detailed stuff but
basically you want to start as general
as possible to get the overall shape of
things and then get more specific so
with this cube let's see I'm just gonna
make this edit the bowl right out the
gates here and it looks like I'll turn
off snapping yeah
somewhere in there I'm just doing this
by eye I know that a lot of people not a
lot of people it's it's necessary when
say like you're modeling a car to have
you know like a plane back here and then
another plane over here and then even
like a top down one you know all right
and you use that as your reference you
have your front back side profile and
then top and that's a way to do this but
we don't have that right now we're just
going off of off of the eye right here
all right so I want to get I want to
start with this main V piece right in
here okay so I'm just gonna scale this
down to what I think is about the size
of that thing right there and it is
editable so I'm just gonna make a slice
down here I'm going to hit KL that's
gonna be like a little loop cut here so
I hold shift it'll snap to the center
and then we'll just pull these two
points forward just a bit cuz there is a
bit of there's a bit of an angle on that
right cool and I'm just gonna grab this
back face these back to and move them in
a little bit so roughly that is this
piece right here okay so next what I'll
do is we'll get symmetry going in a
minute here but I want to make this cube
about as thick as this cube so once
again I'm just gonna do this by eye I'm
coming here hit NB and that's gonna
bring up our wireframe view
all right in theirs it was just about
fine okay and then we're gonna scale it
on the X here and just walk it over
and all I'm doing is just pushing and
pulling different points and faces which
eventually will build up to something
like this so you know you just got to
stick in there hang in
all right something like that we'll deal
with that cross-section later and make
sure you guys save your scene because I
don't think I've saved mine yet yeah
so to set up cemetry really all you need
to do here is grab your geometry okay
and we want to the cemetry is based off
of the anchor point right so right now
if we throw symmetry on this I'm going
to select the cube just hold down alt
and we'll grab our symmetry here it's
gonna flip it there's two of them you
can see right there but it's flipping it
based off of the anchor point so if we
move the anchor point to so now I'm
moving the actual object I want to move
just the anchor point so you can hit L
or this button right over here and that
will allow you to just move the anchor
point and I'm gonna get it right at zero
but this is saying negative so I'm gonna
start from scratch here and we'll get
rid of the symmetry and we want to get
that anchor point right at zero so now
when we apply the symmetry it's gonna
work just perfectly go right over to the
other side because the symmetry is
looking at the center point and it's
gonna flip it along the center point
all right so it looks like on this cube
here there's like a little cut out for
the wing so what we can do here is make
a couple cuts so you can see how this
line it starts to angle right based off
of the left side but on the right side
it's flat so what we can do here is
actually make a cut it can be arbitrary
cuts one and two and I'm gonna hit ul
and go to line mode select both of those
I'll select one at a time actually I'm
at T and if I just scale it this should
work maybe you have to hold ctrl and go
to point mode
weird this should be working
maybe have to type it in
oh it's because I'm still an anchor
point mode I still think your point mode
selected I'll click this and now now
it's gonna work so basically you can
flatten this out into a straight line by
just coming down here and typing in zero
for the Z scale and that will perfectly
line up and be a straight line I'll do
the same here all right so I just move
this and I'm looking down here to see
which numbers are moving but it's the Z
right here z scale Z slider so I know
just zero that out okay and what KL once
again and we'll look at our geometry
here we can see that this line right
here kind of comes back about halfway
through this this piece lengthwise so
it's kind of somewhere like right in
there okay
so now what we'll do is I'm just gonna
get rid of this geometry there and you
should be able to fill these holes here
let's do or will actually will bridge it
I'm just gonna bridge from with the line
mode selected from the top and I'm gonna
hold and come down will bridge that okay
and we'll bridge that and finally right
in there and you can see if we turn
symmetry back on it's happening over
here on this side so we only have to do
half the work that is a huge time-saving
tip here only do half the work it isn't
necessary to do the whole thing
so are you guys following along right
now are you modeling along with me right
now or you guys just just enjoying your
afternoon or evening okay so we have
that done let's get this seam right in
here so I'm going to let's see I'm just
gonna scoot this over a little bit so
I'm gonna select I hate ul grab all
those lines there scoot this over okay
and then grab this one and I'm hitting W
to go between local and world
orientation here so that's about good
okay and then I'm gonna grab let's see
here let's grab this front piece here
okay and we're just gonna bring these
two in T and we'll scale it down to
about about about there okay and we just
want these front two lines to be flush
so I'm holding shifts like both and I'm
just gonna move these up and eyeball
that right here
so right now that's kind of the base of
the glider so you guys are asking a lot
about blender and stuff I think blender
is great but honestly I think you guys
it will depends here right if you've
been doing 3d for a very long time then
it doesn't matter what program you're
using because most of these you know
tools and workflows and everything and
techniques they transfer doesn't matter
what program you're using it just
matters you know who the artist is
they're gonna be able to make anything
work if you're just starting out or if
you're rather if you're on a budget
blender is I mean there's there's
nothing better because it's free but
personally I love cinema 4d I've been
using it for a long time I put most of
my time into c4d in 3ds max but recently
c40 has been my program of choice for
the last few years and I I don't see
myself turning any other direction I
love it a lot so I'm gonna keep going
with it all right
so now it looks like we have this back
piece it looks like there's kind of like
a cylindrical kind of thing back here
which connects a pipe actually it looks
like it's like a half sphere so one
thing that you guys need to do here is
actually reference look at your
reference images and take good note here
I'm looking at this right here there's
this like half sphere looking thing or
half cylinder rather so we'll basically
just model that and stick it right on
the side right there so I'm just gonna
grab a cylinder and I believe I know
what spheres you can do this yeah you
can slice it boom so it's just right
down the middle okay and we want to
orient it just like it is in the
reference okay
and I'm going to probably leave it lower
poly right now we don't need to go crazy
with anything we can always subdivide
things so I'm gonna make that editable
and I'm gonna scale this down and I'll
scale it down and it looks like it's a
little if if if this was a square right
based on the reference image it looks
like it's a little longer than it is
tall so I say something like that okay
and let's just move this so this is our
live side this is our copy sides that
will keep it on this live side we'll get
it right back in here everything is just
by eye
we'll bring it down and it looks like
there is a cylinder back here so if I
hold with an object selected if I hold
ctrl and make a new object that new
object will spawn on the object I have
selected so I'm gonna do just that with
the cylinder okay
and we're gonna make basically we're
making this bar this cross bar here so
let's do radius of 2.5 inches 1.5
something like that and we want this to
be right in the middle okay so we can
just hit well we can do a couple things
we want the why it looks like this is
the X to be writing but also I'm gonna
zero that out then we want it to come up
a little bit and I think back just a bit
to get it right in place and we can
bring it in so that is like our back
back little cross piece here so let's
[Music]
while we're here let's make a couple
cuts my head KL with the cylinder
selected we go to line mode and let's
see let's actually grab all of these
edges are faces rather and we're gonna
we're gonna inset them extrude them and
then bring it back out so real quick so
extra to inner the shortcut is M W all
right and we're gonna execute that and
it looks weird it's doing some weird
stuff but we don't need to go that far
we just want to go just a little bit
okay and we're gonna hit em T all right
and that's extrude another time-saving
tip is to learn your shortcuts very very
very important but real quick I'm gonna
undo this because I want to do it to
these polygons as well okay so once
again you can either right click to find
extrude inner and notice the shortcut MW
that's gonna save you a ton of time
learn those shortcuts mt4 extrude you
can right click and hit extrude
and then we're gonna extrude inner again
but this time instead ring it in we're
gonna bring out so MW and I'll just come
into here just to see how far that's
going perfect and then we'll do an MT
again for extrude awesome awesome and
then I think we can probably bevel this
real quick
unless it's gonna get weird down there
m/s is your bevel tool is it should be
yeah a mess but we want to bevel if you
hold so here's another tip you have a
bunch of polygons selected and you want
to select the outer edges so I would
just hold ctrl and if you switch to say
line mode it'll select all the lines
that correlate with those polygons you
got selected so I'm hold ctrl just get
rid of those same over here and come in
ms once again and there we go
with a nice little bevel but it totally
jacks this thing up I don't know how to
get around that
[Music]
maybe it has like a bunch of yeah that's
a tricky one so I wonder if we hold
shift and throw a bevel deformer yeah
it's probably gonna do same thing yeah I
don't know how to get around that one
we'll come back to this because we're
still modeling everything as a whole or
blocking everything in okay so let's
just make sure it looks like it's inset
a little bit more so I'm gonna grab the
cylinder bring that in and I'm looking
at this edge here and you just want to
find that eagle-eye right you want to
really line things up and really take
note of where things are in in 3d space
with your reference okay so we want to
duplicate this over so we're not going
to control drag it over we're gonna do
the cemetery thing okay because then we
don't have the texture to different
things so once again I'm going to enable
the axis mode here or you can hit L and
we just want X axis to be zeroed out so
I'll hit 0 on there and then that should
be fine we're gonna hold down alt hold
down this subdivision surface here and
then let go on symmetry and now symmetry
is not working like we wanted to by
default so we're gonna mirror it and
we're just gonna test out these
different planes here and there it is X
Z and we'll save our scene and we'll
make sure
yep things are looking pretty good here
okay so the most next most general thing
we have on our list let's see so there's
these pipes around here there's the wing
let's do let's do the wing
I'm feeling that Kyle Kyle Humphrey dude
wait
Kyle Humphrey
wait you did those did you do those
fight scenes that's like that's like
from years ago if you're the same guy
that I'm thinking about did you do like
these random fight scenes with like your
brother or something or your friend
that's crazy that if that's true that's
like that's a blast from the past right
there
thanks for the super chat Kyle that's
awesome man that is so cool alright I'm
gonna keep going here I'm gonna keep
modeling so our wing is basically just a
cube with some funky stuff here on the
side which can be probably a little
spline tool action so let's see we have
a cylinder in here so let's grab let's
grab a cylinder and instead of rotating
it we can just say instead of plus y
we'll do plus Z okay and we'll bring the
radius in bring it over
something like that and this will this
will eventually just be attached to the
wing okay and then we're going to throw
the wing into a cemetry object as well
oh my god Kyle it is the same person wow
that's crazy man that is insane I got to
check out your channel man because that
has been a while it has been years I
used to watch those fights those things
were awesome okay so continuing on here
all right so we have our cylinder which
actually if you look closely it goes
beyond that side piece there so I'm just
gonna scale it up and bring it in just a
bit all right so that right there is
looking nice and we'll build off of this
so I'm with this object select it I'll
hold ctrl and make a cube we'll scale
this cube down I'm gonna make it
editable and shrink it down just a bit
let's bring it out and over okay to
about here
and it looks like this wing definitely
is oriented down so we want to rotate
this thing down like this but we don't
want this top piece to go up so we need
to change where the Anchor Point is
situated on the geometry here so I'm
gonna press L and we can do this you
know this way here we can move it over
and eyeball it but why not just be sure
about what we're doing so I'm gonna take
that off and there's actually this tool
I set it as a custom button for myself
it's called the axis Center tool and you
can hit shift C and type axis Center and
you can drag this and it'll be a little
button if you use it a lot right so with
my object selected my cube I'm gonna hit
the axis Center and you're prompted with
a little dialog box all we need to do is
this is our x-axis and it's pointing to
the positive the opposite is the
negative so we want to push this all the
way to the left side of the box here so
I'm gonna go negative x alright the
slider is going to the left negative
because the arrow is pointing to the
right that would be positive if I
execute it's gonna go that way boom
so it's snapped all the way to the left
and that tool is very very very handy I
use it all the time so it looks like
this wing is wider here then probably
around right around there
okay and we're gonna scale this out and
we'll rotate it down rotate it down
something like something like that okay
and we can see that it looks like this
wing at least from this view is pinched
together so this side is smaller right
so it's probably something like that and
it might come up a little bit more or
something like that right
and also it's a little skinnier I feel
like this is a little skinnier so once
again I'm switching between world view
or wise straight up and I hit W and
it'll switch to local orientation okay
world orientation and local orientation
so now it's moving based on the
orientation of the geometry here so
that's exactly what we want we're gonna
hit T and we're gonna scale it down you
can see the difference this is the local
scale versus world scale you see how it
like shifts it like that we want to keep
things clean so you're gonna bring it in
a little bit just like that and it's
pretty obvious there's just the cylinder
on the backside of this okay so I'll
hold ctrl I wonder if it does it with
edges um I guess not I guess it just
does it as the whole piece so go + C
again and you see how even the
orientation is right if we were to just
spawn this cylinder at 0-0 we'd have to
move it all around and get it right in
place here there's some different tools
you can use to do that but the easiest
way is to select a piece that you know
this thing's gonna be attached to hold
ctrl spawn your new geometry and it'll
already be lined up even the orientation
is right you can see if I go to if I go
to local orientation I can just slide
this right down and it's perfectly in
line everything lines up nice which is
what you want you want it to be as clean
as possible so let's just click here
just the radius what's gone
yeah just the the radius so it's
probably something like that maybe a
little smaller cool and it looks like it
comes forward just beyond the wing like
that and then just at the end so I think
it just needs to scale in a little bit
just like that
I'm glad you guys are down for all this
it's cool to see you guys excited we we
do a weekly contest on the discord
server which you guys aren't a part of
the link is in the description of this
livestream and we'll be announcing the
winners of the weekly challenge right
after the lesson here and the prompt was
spongebob there are some incredible
renders so I'm very excited to show you
guys those okay so let's set up let's
just parent all this stuff together here
okay and then we can have it be flipped
over to the other side so real quick
let's grab this here this cylinder and
we're gonna put everything into the
cylinder because the orientation is
right this is where we want the wing to
rotate from so let's grab this end
cylinder we'll put that into let's just
take both of these things actually I'm
going I'm I'm like two steps ahead of
myself
I keep contradicting okay here we go I'm
gonna select the cylinder alright we
know our anchor point is right there
that's where we want our wing to turn
from so I'm hold ctrl and I'm going to
spawn a null object so there's a null
object right in there and I'm gonna just
put all of these things into the null
object so now it rotates properly like a
wing should okay and we're going to
title this wing and you want to be as
organized as possible so you're gonna
want to rename things based off of their
description so that you can just know
what is going on at all times they're
gonna be a lot of a lot cubes and
cylinders right so with that okay what
we'll do is we will make this
symmetrical okay so select the wing I'm
gonna hit L or enable this little access
tool over here and for the
x-axis zero that out so it's right in
the middle select owing will hold down
alt and we'll make it a symmetrical
object and now we're starting to build
this thing out and real quick if you
don't hold alt and you just click on
symmetry you're gonna have two main
really drag the wing into the symmetry
okay but if you hold alt it's
automatically going to make I I don't
know the terminology it's in a I don't
think it's an effector maybe it's a de
former but it's gonna make the the
cemetry an automatic parent of the
geometry you had selected so we are
making our way downtown all right
let's let us continue so this middle
stuff this is the next challenge we have
ahead of us here is the middle stuff
okay so it looks like we have a pipe
across here we got a pipe going back
here and these pipes are built out a
little bit and it looks like they have
these like plates holding them down okay
so yeah I'm already thinking of a fun
way to do this I think we can do this
with with a spline with like a what you
would call it what do you call it you
know one of those things um oh not a
lathe where where are things here and oh
shoot I've lost my way what this is s22
I'm new spline mask but I'll sweep sweep
that's one time up so we'll go to top
view okay I'm just gonna make make a
little thing here Oh Jason
dude thanks for the super chat much
appreciated don't forget to grab some
kombucha I will grab some kombucha right
now in fact I could I could use a little
something I'll be right back
thank you sir we got the ginger aid not
a sponsor guys we're not sponsored by
kombucha I wish oh my goodness I wish
sponsored by gt's kombucha that'd be
incredible maybe one day maybe when I
when I strike gold
but thanks Jason appreciate you man
let's let's get this pipe going here
right the quickest way to get some nice
pipes all right so we'll go spline pen
and we're not gonna worry about any
curved points or anything right now we
just want to get some points laid out
all right we got four points we got one
two three four and that's it I'm not
even gonna worry about getting them
lined up because I'm gonna do that right
now so we'll let's see if you notice
right I'm moving the axis but not the
geometry so it's undo that hit L because
we had access mode selected and I'm
gonna just line this up and I'm looking
down here
I probably grabbed both of these and do
this like scale trick scale on the X
just zero that out same here
I'll grab these zero it out to make sure
that they're perfectly in line you know
what I mean I did this one for the Z
looks like we're all good and we
definitely want hard interpolation on
all this stuff and there's probably yeah
there's probably a faster way of doing
this probably just spawn a square spline
and be done with it but I guess I'm
doing this one the hard way anyway this
is what we got right here and we'll go
back to 3d view here and we'll bring the
spline up just like that and why is it
why is it not
okay I guess it is level I just butyl
viewport trickery
so let's see let's go to our spline and
let's make a circle spline okay
this circle spline is gonna determine
how thick the pipe is so let's scale it
down probably want it something like
like that and with the spline and the
circle selected I'm gonna hold ctrl alt
and then I'll grab a sweep boom and it
looks really nice so these edges are
really hard I'm gonna go into the spline
we'll go top view we'll grab our points
let's hide the sweep for now let's grab
both of those and we're gonna right
click and we will chamfer just a little
something to smooth it out and when we
sweep it now it's gonna look nicer okay
that's great I think that works just
perfect okay so we have this pipe
hanging it looks like they kind of
conjoined together cuz this one comes
down and goes down for like this little
hang glider thing so I'll just let that
sit just right there on the geometry now
we need to bulk out these little bits
here lengthwise and this little piece
here and these little pieces back here
and that's gonna be super simple we're
gonna do this pretty quickly and we're
also gonna make use of our symmetry here
okay so I'm gonna take the sweep and I'm
just gonna make it editable by hitting C
and that's gonna turn all this into
actual geometry that we can mess with
I'm gonna hit KL that's our knife tool
we're gonna start cutting up here we'll
go one and two okay and then for the
side here we'll go
one and two okay and now you can see
that it's not symmetrical so we
definitely want to cut this in half and
then throw some symmetry on it so by
holding shift we're not hitting that
midpoint we could have done it before we
made those two cuts but I'll just make a
cut right in the middle and you should
if we go to let's see if zoom in and
we'll select all these hitting ul okay
and I'm hitting W to bring up little
gizmo and we'll just zero out the X so
we know that's right down the center
okay and then we'll select with the
rectangle selection all these points
will delete them okay so now we have
half of our pipe and already the
orientation is right in the center so
we'll hold alt and we'll let go on
symmetry and now you can see those cuts
all over there okay so now we only have
to do this once I'm gonna hit ul on
polygon mode okay and we're going to
extrude this so MT or you can
right-click and extrude and again
shortcuts huge time-saver definitely
want to learn your shortcuts and we'll
scale this up you can see that is kind
of giving us this effect here and I'm
actually going to instead of extruding
the geometry here which I probably could
do now let's just do that yeah let's
just do that okay
I'm gonna select these two here we're
going to extrude em or actually you can
control drag this out as well
yeah control drag that basically does
the same thing and then we want these
points right here we want this line to
be straight vertical right 90-degree
angles so we'll hold what T and we'll
scale it on the z-axis until they're
right at 0 but instead of eyeballing it
all you have to do is come down in here
zero out the Z and now it's perfect
it is wonderful okay so I think what I'm
gonna do I'm actually gonna probably um
grab this third one down here okay and
then scale this out and zero out the Z
from there because I want to raise this
up a little bit right then we'll do the
same over here okay we'll grab let's see
one two and three okay we have this
going down the line here we'll hold
control bring it out and now it's the X
that we want to scale to zero so that's
nice and flush and you can see it's
doing the thing on the other side I'm
looking great let's turn on ambient
occlusion so we can kind of see what's
going down it's starting to look really
really nice you guys can get the idea
here like you just build it from the
ground up like this and we're gonna get
in here we're gonna bubble these edges
and make it look really nice but this is
all it really is and this is what Ian
did when when he modeled that drop ship
and he uses blender so these techniques
transfer to any program it's Universal
knowledge you can take this and make
some really cool stuff with it pretty
quickly so we're gonna keep going here
I'm gonna build this out on the stream
and finish it up and I think it's gonna
look really nice
250 live viewers that is awesome thank
you guys for joining thanks for hanging
out and let me get some ambient music
going I got that uh playlist for you
guys the ambient playlist in the
description of this video so that's not
gonna be listening to right now
little Spotify playlist super chill good
for focus concentration studying
sleeping all those things vision vision
vision tantal thank you so much for the
super chat appreciate you that's great
let me just connect these bone phones
real quick why you know connect
bear with me all a little technical
difficulties here just trying to get
this this music connected there we go
all right let's let's continue so this
piece here it looks like it comes out a
lot further okay so I'm just gonna grab
the appropriate geometry one two and
three and I'm just gonna pull this out
and it looks like it comes in a little
bit so I'm going to scale it well I'm
gonna scale it in by just a hair
you know just probably just right there
perfect absolutely wonderful
so there's screws in here we can deal
with that stuff in a second what else
what else it looks like there is some
stuff going on back here with these
little cross-section pieces so I'm gonna
come in here let's maybe bring this one
out a little bit to just a little bit
cool cool alright um what should we do
next what should we do next
um this piece here this little like
graphics card looking thing here let's
get this going so it looks to me like
you have this little cross-section which
is a very basic cube set up here and I'm
imagining there's like a central kind of
energy system right in here so maybe
it's like like a little piece I don't
know what what shape this would be like
a like an old-style clock you know a
standing clock where it comes up and
then it's a circle and then it comes
back down so it's like the end of a
thick popsicle stick so maybe we'll get
that piece going there and then what
else it looks like we have this obvious
geometry up here this stuff is probably
duplicated back here I'm going to assume
and another thing to note depending on
what you're using this for you don't
need to get as detailed as you might
think if you're not gonna see this from
the top you know if you're gonna see
from a certain angle then you know all I
need to focus on the bottom more or if
you're only gonna see it from like the
top and it's gonna have this little net
up here then you know you don't need to
get real detailed with this stuff down
here so that's another thing you can do
for saving time is only modeling and
detailing the things or the areas you
know you're gonna be seeing so let's um
let's hide the figure let's go on the
top view
and let's just model out this piece
right here let's block this stuff out
what's the best way to do this what's
the best way to do this um I think we'll
do we'll do some symmetry leave some
symmetry with a cube and the cool thing
is like there's there's always different
ways to go about solving a problem in 3d
so the way I'm doing it is not the only
way okay so let's get this piece right
looks like it comes right up to the edge
almost like right in there okay and then
we're gonna grab this edge and we're
going to pull it out to somewhere
somewhere here I think and we'll go 45
degrees on this
something like that okay then we're to
hold ctrl and drag it out again and
we'll go another 45 degrees but that
looks janky okay we want that to be
straight so I wonder instead of rotating
it let's scale it on the X will zero it
out and same for the position we will
not do that we want to bring it right
into the middle and I think this one
will just do by eye there's this black
line which is zero and I think that's
good now it looks like because of the
way we've rotated things looks like this
is a little off okay so I wonder what
the best way of doing this is other than
by eye cuz I'm going to grab this point
and make sure only select visible
elements is checked off and we just want
to move that so it looks like the
thickness between this point in that
point
matches basically the thickness should
be the same all throughout this entire
thing
so that's obviously G skinny and
something like something like that I
think is fine and now we also want the
thickness of this piece and this piece
to be the same and I think this piece
looks a little skinny
so that feels that feels about right to
me okay oh another quick tip if you move
the camera don't mean to you can hold
ctrl shift Z and that will undo camera
movement it's really handy for when you
have a tracked camera with a bunch of
data on it you move it accidentally like
oh no just ctrl shift C and it'll undo
that stuff so now we want to flip this
to the other side so we want to move the
axis here boom right at zero so we'll
just type that down in there we'll
select that I'll throw it on symmetry
and boom we got some nice symmetry going
now I think I think this piece is like
angled up a little bit I think I think
so what we'll do is go to our symmetry
we want to angle it up from this point
back here okay we want to rotate this
thing up like that so I'm going to use
the axis center tool again and we're
gonna get this minus Z we want it here
right so we want to go this way which is
minus Z and plus X so minus C plus X
execute and it's gonna snap right to the
point we want now when we rotate this
we'll just go up by a little bit okay
and then we'll come in here we'll grab
this edge
and I think what's the best way doing
this what do we rotate it or do we scale
it I'm gonna go with scale for now okay
so I'm just gonna make sure my Z scale
is at zero that didn't work
why did that not work maybe it's maybe
it's something else so we want that to
be straight up-and-down which that looks
like to me yeah zero what
or is it X it's not X
that's very strange because I type in I
type in zero down here
yeah I definitely want world I want
world scale maybe I have to do it yeah
come on come on maybe you have to do
that no that's not right
that's definitely all right
yeah I'm stumped on that one I'm just
doing that one by I want to spend too
much time focusing on that stuff if I
can just get it by eye real quick
so next there's this piece here which
I'm imagining it looks like an old clock
so I'm gonna go top down and I'm just
gonna draw this out with the pen tool
okay so it's gonna be something I'm
gonna turn on the snapping workplane
snap all that stuff is good to go so if
I want to do a point let's say on this
line here I'll come up to this point
here and I'm just gonna count I'm gonna
go one two three four five six oh I'll
go over six as well one two three four
five six and another six one two three
four five six back down to this point
and back down to this point and then now
we have to move it over with this whole
thing over we want to Center our axis
with the axis Center tool well zero
actually we'll do point Center and we'll
execute so it's right in the middle and
then now we'll just move this whole
thing to zero and now I'm gonna grab
these top two points Oh another thing I
want to close the spline so that last
bit selected boom so I make a little
square and I'm gonna grab these points
there right click and we're going to
chamfer and we could have done this with
a with a cube as well where where are
you Scheffer there you are okay boom
there you go forms that old like Beauty
and the Beast clock shape all right and
then we'll hold down alt and we'll just
drop an extruder on it and it's way too
intense just right down so bring it down
where you at where you at offset is 100
centimeters we just want I don't know
four inches what does that look like
sure
okay now I want to solo these two here
maybe Plus this and I'm using a plugin
called magic solo I believe it's called
yeah magic solo it's free definitely
look it up it is awesome
so from the side view
right in here this is just this is just
bugging me I waste a lot of time by
being a perfectionist I really do so I
want to get this with grid point
snapping on that actually works out I'll
turn snapping off so we'll grab this
little clock thingy and let's scale it
down move it in just connect these
pieces just about there
cool and let's just Center you can also
hit there's the center access to button
you just click that and it should work
and if it doesn't that's what I just do
the axis Center tool and it's asking
it's not working because why isn't it
not working include children include all
objects interesting
interesting well it is in the center
which is what we want so let's come back
in here and see what's going on it looks
like this piece there's like this X
piece which connects up into a cylinder
so what we'll do is make a cylinder
right in the middle of everything okay
zero zero but we'll just spawn a
cylinder okay and I'm gonna move
everything besides the camera and the
cylinder I'm gonna move it down so that
zero zero is the actual like power
source for this things I'll scale that
down cool we'll grab the extrude we'll
bring this in and we'll bring this back
edge I'm actually gonna make this
extrude editable so we can just get in
here start getting serious let's get on
the cylinder a little bit more and then
I'll grab everything besides our camera
in that cylinder in object mode and just
make sure everything is generally lined
up to that energy point and I think that
looks really really nice and to go step
further we can just grab our extrude and
just make sure that this lines up right
there cool that's just by eye so now
what I'll do is we'll just work on this
little cool energy looking thing here so
I'm gonna up the segments it looks like
we're looking a little low on this I'll
go to like yeah a little go to 48 32
whatever and let's scale this thing down
I'll make it editable and we'll scale it
down
and it looks like it's sitting right on
top of that piece there okay and there's
some detailing here so the first thing
I'm seeing is it's definitely in set and
extruded down okay so I'm gonna select
I'm not gonna do that let's grab our
selection tool make sure only select
visible elements is checked on now okay
cuz we don't wanna get the things behind
this we just want the top and let's
extrude in ur MW let's try that again
MW come in something like that we want
to extrude it down something something
like like that cool and then I'm gonna
grab this outer ring or the inner ring
rather boom and just bring that down a
little bit because it looks like that's
going on right in there and now there's
a couple like incisions here it looks
like there's like a top plate and a
bottom plate and there's like a thicker
piece right here in the middle so what
I'll do is actually let's see let's
let's hit KL and let's just chop it
right there I'm holding on shift in
right there and I'm gonna go ul grab
these to extrude is Mt okay and we're
going to scale those in and we will
always come back and bevel this stuff
because there's no such thing as a
90-degree angle I'm gonna make sure
everything is bubbled
so that's the basic shape of that here
it looks like we have this like graphics
card looking thing here that comes up to
this point and it might just have like a
little cylinder that wraps around and
kind of grabs this and holds it together
and I'm betting that's the case on both
sides okay and also I might just grab
let's see this I'll make a new cylinder
I'll scale it down
and I'll make it edit the bowl and just
scale it down and it looks like there's
like something down here going on as
well just for a little added detail so
you can see we're getting there let me
bring up the octane live viewer just to
see what we're working with and if I
just render the scene real quick we'll
get rid of let's dock this window I'm
gonna grab this little line these three
lines drag it to those three lines then
now you can see we got that and now you
can see our figure we need to turn this
off in render view and I'm just gonna
save make a quick HDRI here just to see
what see what we're working with our
attributes those are hidden so I'm gonna
drag those up into there so we can see
what's going on we'll go in here I'm
just gonna grab let's see VFX materials
HDR I will grab the corridor studio and
we'll just crank that up to like three
or something two
[Music]
that's funny there's Ren and Dean it
looks like Matt that's me in my desk
so yeah this is kind of what we're
working with right now you can see that
these edges definitely need to be
beveled they're way too way too sharp
it's very low poly right now we're about
an hour in to our model right now
so yeah there's still there's still a
lot of work to do a lot of detail to add
and you guys can see once again how you
you know we're starting with cubes and
we're building this up or building this
up and then you'd eventually you'd
texture this thing and it looks super
nice so I'm gonna keep I'm gonna keep
going we're here you know we're going in
I'm gonna grab let's see let's move grab
another hgri something maybe studio
and I'm just going to make a new octane
sky here and just change it from primary
to visible alright so we can get like a
nice nice view of this thing and I'll
turn off the f-stop cool very cool
alright let's continue guys penguin I
don't know how to bake normals I simply
do not know how to do that that is
something that I need to learn is a weak
point for me and I need to get better at
it so in time in time I shall learn
because it'd be cool to just uh you know
upload this asset somewhere for you guys
to download but ok let's let's keep
going on this main central unit piece
let's get this black piece right here
I'm trying to think the best way the
best way to do this honestly is probably
with with a cube yeah okay so um here's
how I'm seeing it in my head we have a
cube here at 0 0 we're gonna scale this
down I'll make it editable I'm gonna
scale it on the Y let's let's move it
back this way now you have these little
feet these pegs they stop right about
there okay and we'll grab this piece
here will scale it it comes this thing
comes right up and into this whole thing
okay so we want to bring this top piece
down
about there okay and my plan is to bevel
these edges at the end so it looks like
it kind of wraps around this thing
everything starts from these cubes it's
very very simple when it just starts
from a cube or a cylinder so now what
I'm gonna do it looks like this piece
definitely comes down it's angled down
and it comes down even further on this
little step here but before I do that I
think I'm going to make some cuts I'm
gonna KL alright and KL let's see k well
what am I talking about here
KL it's a loop path cut and that is
under select I believe I believe
where is loop path cut if I right click
it's sitting right there loop path cut
okay
KL that is your shortcut okay so it
looks like I'm trying to make this cut
right here so I'd say right about there
okay and then we have some cuts coming
up along the edge of all this stuff
so I'll go one holding shift I'll go on
there and I'll go one there okay then
I'm gonna hit ul and grab with the line
tool I'll grab both of those scale them
apart
okay and then I'm gonna delete in
polygon mode I'm gonna delete these
points and once again we're gonna bridge
things I don't know the bridge shortcut
so I don't use it enough mb mb making
bridges all right let's get that making
bridges MB gotta remember that memorize
those shortcuts somehow guys all right
so it's not as thick as we have it
definitely not as thick so I'm going to
grab the bottom polygons here let's just
solo this we can see what's going on how
nice is that magic solo huh it's the
best one click and it's done all right
all right so it looks looks like these
legs here come down like this
but so does this whole thing so how
would I do this how on earth would I do
this
let me try something let me let me just
hide this
let me grab our cylinder here may hit n
B so I can see the polygons I'm missing
with will go to polygon mode and I want
to grab let's try grabbing like that
Oh actually there's a cool thing if you
do a loop selection ul click and drag
somewhere you should go to click and
drag yeah there you go so if you click
and drag you only select a section right
so I just want that section and I don't
know if this is new in our 22 or if I
was just messing around and discovered
it one day but I'm gonna control drag
these out like that I'm hit T
and I'm gonna scale these points so
they're flat okay so we're gonna hit Z
we're gonna zero those out and yeah I'm
only using this one reference photo
I know usually it's not the way you do
it but sometimes when you don't have all
the reference photos the side view
profile view top-down all that all the
views you know you can't you want to
still be able to function right so
that's what we're doing right now then
now what I'll do is I'm gonna grab let's
grab one to zoom in here one two three
four same on the edge one two three four
okay well control drag these out as well
I lied before we do that let's just grab
all of these bring it down and that's
what I was trying to get around okay
that's that's what we couldn't do with
just the cube is I needed to make sure
that this thing connected all the way
around and when you bring this down each
one of these polygons is being you know
bent at a different angle
all right so we'll grab the one two
three four one two three four and we'll
go to local view locally to it okay that
does work when control drag these down
once again even more something like that
and they splay out okay these pieces
splay out so maybe before I do that how
would I do this let's grab all these
pieces and there's probably a faster way
to grab all these I'm gonna grab all
these pieces and I want to I want to
point them to the corners of this thing
so I'm gonna scale them up so they just
reach about the corner
you know if this line continues it's
gonna hit that corner okay and now I'm
goin two three four same deal okay and
we're gonna going to control drag these
down to the bottom and we're going to
scale them out just like that
sweet and I want to thicken this up a
little bit so I'm gonna grab these under
pieces the other side one two three four
all the way down get all that stuff and
we want to I'm just I'm just gonna
simply move these like that and I want
to make this gap a little bit thicker so
with this edge selected or line selected
I'm gonna hit ul and just bring this
down just about there
oh but we also need the inner one as
well so let's make sure we grab both see
now this is getting into a bit more
detail work oh that's part of that geez
okay maybe it's just gonna have to be
the one
but ultimately what I want to do here is
I want to grab let's grab the cylinder
with the cylinder selected I'm gonna
hold ctrl and make another cylinder
scale it down and just so it's a little
thicker than all that and we'll go 32
segments height will bring down to two
inches so I want to basically just make
it like as if there was a ring on this
we scale it in just a little bit more
that was kind of grabbing this and
keeping it together
and you notice that I'm not I'm not
forcing it I'm not trying to like have
these pieces be all one piece that's
definitely another time-saving tools
like you can make this geometrically
perfect or you could say excuse me you
can say it's just gonna be fine because
you know you're not gonna be able to
tell at the end of the day that's such a
small detail again what are you using
this thing for if it's just for a shot
or you know distant thing like it's
you're not gonna need all this detail
you had to died totally correct I lost
there for a second I start to lose my
voice towards any of these things okay
alright let's look at this let's look at
this so we have these like three little
bits of geometry here we know we're
gonna want to use like an octane
emissive texture to light that bit up so
see these three here these three lights
separated I think what I'm gonna do is
grab the cylinder okay and go I believe
you are KL once again kale with the
cylinder selected edges selected let's
go in here and we want to chop I'm gonna
chop there and we want to chop there
probably and we just want to get a
segment here segments with like five or
six so from top down view there's 32 of
these so we'll go one two
we'll go six and we'll go we'll go six
and
this probably a better way of trying to
figure out how many of these will add
one will take away just until there's
one two three four five one two three
four one two three four five six one two
three four five one two three four
that's close enough and I'm just gonna
take that and make it day uh let's see
set selection boom set selection so now
in the future when we come in here we
have those polygons selected for an
octane emissive light right in there and
honestly we might as well just inset
these a little bit so I'm gonna hit Mt
extrude them down just a little bit
so that's looking real cool right there
let's keep going let's get back to this
detail or not detail let's get back to
general general building up of this
whole thing right so we have this back
side we need to connect I think we can
certainly duplicate with some symmetry
we can duplicate this piece here um as
well as probably this piece honestly so
how would we how would we do that what's
the best way to do this we might have to
just chop this cylinder down the middle
maybe undo all of that stuff because it
wasn't symmetrical and we'll go top view
we'll come in here we'll go to point
mode and we'll grab all these points
that aren't associated with that half
will cut it right in half and we'll grab
the cylinder and with alt held down
we're going to just pop it into a little
symmetry and we need to tweak the
settings on symmetry here so it would be
an zy maybe a X by the way there we go
X Y XY flip okay boom so that's getting
that and then we also want to do the
same for this little this symmetry here
so we need to make sure our orientation
or our center point is set so we'll make
sure we have the enable access tool
selected you can hit L for that as well
we'll get it right in the middle zero
zero zero perfect and willing to throw
that symmetry into another symmetry
right over there on the side
perfect okay and then the last thing I
want to do is take this piece and this
extrude I'm gonna hold ctrl to duplicate
it make sure you're not in axis mode and
here's another okay so we want to
orientate or yeah we're half way through
the stream here guys
starting with my mind okay we want to
orient this or rotate this from the
middle point from the center point so we
just want to move the axis once again to
zero zero zero and we'll do it again and
that's why we set ourselves up being
right in the middle that's the benefit
of being right in the middle is you just
got to get those access points right in
there I'm going to move this down and
just take some creative liberties move
this down like this but it doesn't look
it doesn't really look like there's a
piece there so I think what I'm gonna do
is maybe scale this down from that point
so it's kind of like a you know not so
all this stuff
so we'll go right I'll go like right in
there I'm gonna grab this piece I'm just
kind of doing some guesswork here I
don't want to get this lined up just
about there okay and then we'll probably
have to grab let's see this is a cemetry
piece no let's go this can just extend
underneath and I don't think anyone's
gonna be too upset about that
we'll just get that I like a little sub
step right down under there cool and I
want to make sure that these pieces are
fitting nice so let's grab these
polygons we're gonna solo let's see
we're pushing solo this and this some of
those and I'd like to just grab these
pieces and set them just right one two
three four you can also just kind of
like do a clean sweep you're here and
then hold control to deselect those
let's just get that see did properly and
then I'm gonna grab let's see let's grab
these edges one two three four as well
as those okay and I'm going to go in a
side view here and just move them so
they're seated properly
awesome awesome awesome things are
starting to look pretty cool
nothing's beveled yet but you can see
the more detail we add in it's just
getting nicer and nicer and you just
have to take the time that's all
what's up Manav welcome welcome
thanks for staying hey we're up to 375
people in the live feed right now this
is awesome guys thank you for joining
thanks for joining me
yeah we're just modeling some stuff you
know we're learning about some efficient
modeling techniques I want to show you
guys how easy it is to make something
that it first might seem a little
complicated but just by using cylinders
and cubes you can really start to build
this thing out and get a really cool
look let's get a Sun in here just to see
just to see what's going down
so we can really get to see our our
detail here with the Sun and maybe we'll
just make it a little overcast by
boosting up the turbidity we'll go like
four or something or maybe well maybe
we'll go three this doesn't really
matter I'm just doing some stuff to make
it look nice CGI Bob Ross dude that's
amazing I love it all right let's
continue guys so looking at this
geometry we have oh we got what do we
have left we have this underside stuff
it looks like like gas tanks or
something and this this pipe continues
underneath the bottom side it comes down
under here and I'm guessing it's holding
a like a gas tank kind of thing it looks
like the gas tank is connected to the
pipe which is then connected to the
actual glider okay and I'm assuming the
gas tank you looks like have these
handlebars that are coming in here and
all of this stuff is symmetrical so
we're gonna model one of these gas tanks
it looks like there's some some pipes
connecting here from these maybe that
these are the fuel source probably this
stuff oh and I just tripped
no never mind yeah this is probably the
fuel source I know those are the burners
maybe the fuel tanks would definitely be
the fuel source what am I talking about
it's going into this thing which is
maybe converting it who knows let's make
some fuel tanks okay let's make a
cylinder because that's basically your
fuel tank will go plus Z minus C I don't
think it really matters and we'll scale
this down
and we'll move it over it looks like
it's situated just underneath so this
Piper here this pipe running along I'll
just say for demonstration sake here
this pipe running along this side right
here looks like it comes down you see
that comes down and around so it's a
little loop of a pipe okay and on that
you have your gas tank okay so I'm gonna
go back to our live side it's our
symmetry side and let's see if we just
can't figure this out real quick yo
thank you for this super chat I'll in
Alphen son often son appreciate you
thank you thank you thank you I will
make sure that uh I send your regards to
rent as well and thank you so much I
really appreciate you appreciate you all
you guys sticking in here with me
okay let's get this gas tank going it's
a little thick perhaps so we'll bring it
down somewhere in there okay
and we'll get the exact placement right
once we get our pipe in but I just want
to block this in real quick so I think
the gas tank is more more of a pill so
what I'm gonna do instead of instead of
redoing this I'm gonna hold control with
the cylinder selected and I'm gonna grab
a capsule okay and we'll set it to plus
a Z as well we'll scale it down but it's
already in place see we don't have to do
any of that extra work and now we just
kind of bring it out that's basically it
I'm setting it to 32 segments 64
awesome awesome awesome awesome sweet
it's looking good
so we probably make some cuts on this
but we'll leave that there for a second
I want to get this pipe going right so
we if we go to our symmetry here we have
this sweep go to top view okay and we
know we want this pipe to continue it
looks like this pipe is all one thing
this piece here so I'm gonna come in
here I'm gonna grab the spline pen tool
I'm gonna make a point probably right
there right in the center of this thing
and we'll hop over to our side view and
we'll run it along the length of this
thing right in about right in about
there okay and the pipe is all jacked up
right now but we'll fix that we go one
two three four and we'll close it off I
basically want to select all these
points here so ctrl a and we'll go hard
interpolation okay and let's just make
sure all this stuff is seated properly
so with the spline selected we can say
our Y is at zero and we'll make sure we
just zero that out it looks like this
one is nice how far does this go on the
Z will seem negative negative eighty I
will set this to negative eighty and I
know I'm doing this the slow way guys
let's see so that's set properly for the
Y we'll say negative 15 we just want
this to all be symmetrical negative 15
okay and then this piece as far as the Y
goes it's negative
we'll say 25 and we just want to make
sure this is also at negative 25 and
this this is hard to say how far this
comes in and out but that basically this
line and this line well eyeball it will
say that's about right okay now what
we'll do is make sure this thing is
seated properly that looks about right
to me it might need to come forward a
little bit somewhere like right right in
there but I guess if it's part of the
same pipe it's gonna be right it's gonna
be set right right in there let's spawn
a circle spline will scale it way down
we don't need to position it really at
all just got scale it down because we're
gonna select both the spline and the
service line hold the ctrl + alt at the
same time and we're just going to drop a
little sweep on it okay wonderful and
you can see you have these really hard
edges so let's let's fix that the spline
selected I'm gonna grab one two three
four okay
those four points we don't need to worry
about those ones up here we're gonna see
them and i'm gonna right click and
chamfer these things
right in there and you can see that's
all bunched up down here it doesn't look
nice so what you can do I believe it's
the sweep settings
maybe spline settings will go the
intermediate points we'll set that to
uniform okay that's gonna do that's
gonna just basically make the slices
uniform across the entire thing but that
is kind of messing it up Naturals
messing it up adaptive is messing it up
sub-divided messing it up okay so let's
try let's try adaptive coming here and
maybe just change the angle is five
degree angle
or what we could do is undo all of this
right and then we can just chamfer these
at different amounts so I'll just do it
in two separate sections I'll grab those
two and I'll chamfer these down to there
and then I'll do these guys a little bit
different I'll chain for these guys
something like that right so I just did
it in two separate sections and we want
this to be symmetrical as well so we'll
make sure we're in the model mode okay
not in polygons not in point we're in
model mode with the sweep selected we
can make this at its wool actually let's
not do that we don't need to does not do
it yet it's already 0 0 that's great so
all you have to do is hold alt drop
symmetry on it and it's right over there
on the other side looking nice okay
what's next I make a quick adjustment
this front face here is a little thick
and our hierarchy is also getting out of
control
let's select all of our stuff that has
to do with lighting and camera and I'm
gonna alt G group it and I'm just gonna
call that scene and we'll drop it down
and then let's take that spline that
reference spline we don't need that
anymore but this cube this is what I
want to edit here just these these two
pieces and move this back probably to
about there and we'll do the same
we'll do the same for these front pieces
too so one and two and I'll just bring
this back as well
top you to see what see what we're doing
which want to line that up cool
awesome
looking good it's starting to look
pretty sweet got these little under
pieces going
I'm an texturing is like one of my
favorite parts gonna be so much fun I
don't know if I'll have enough time to
texture today but maybe throughout the
week on the discord server you guys can
see my progress in the modeling and
texturing Channel but real quick guys
I'm gonna use a restroom real quick
because this bucho you know it's too
good and it's just trying to escape me
so bear back see you guys in two seconds
you
alright back in back at it everybody
doing ok everyone's good and probably
got another uh a little bit on this
make it look nice probably add some
detail to the wings here I start
beveling things but let's finish these
tanks and let's finish these pipes at
the bottom yeah ok so the tank I am
feeling like there's like this little
painted piece I'm seeing so we can
subdivide or separate that rather with a
couple extrudes and some cuts very very
simple here so I'm gonna make this
cylinder or this capsule editable and
I'll simply hit ul for a little loop
selection and just scoot this back okay
and we're gonna grab and polygon mode
we'll grab that with ul once again loop
selection and we're going to extrude
inner so that's M W just a little bit
and then we'll hit MT for extrude let's
actually take note let's take note of
how much we're extruding okay so on the
right ins dialog box we can see we're
extruding negative point six three
negative point six two alright let's
copy that okay and let's go MW once
again to extrude Oh
mw2 extra dinner and then m/t just gonna
hit enter I'm not gonna do that I'm not
gonna do that
let's see I want to
when I extrude this back out by the same
amount so I think I just had to go in
this dialog box and hit enter but make
it positive and there we go now we know
it's the exact amount and then what we
can do now is go to select and set
selection I also made this a button up
here you can hit shift C type set
selection and drag it out make a little
button for you if you always use it now
you're gonna have to go up to window
customization set a start up layout or
save layout as for that to be for those
buttons to still be there all right so
let's see here
yeah let's set that selection cuz we
know it can be different color when we
come back and I'm using a non-commercial
license right now cuz I just got hooked
up from max on I just got a free from
max on because I love their stuff
and they're supporting me I'm supporting
them and I think maybe that's just the
version that was sent over but ain't no
big deal
all right so that's the capsule all
right now what we're gonna want to do is
just make sure it's kind of connected to
this whole thing to this whole Shaboom
so I'm probably gonna do that how am I
gonna do that we can grab this sweep
cemetry we can make the sweep edit the
bowl you can come in here and we'll go
line mode we'll go okay l will make a
couple points that one's already made
for us we don't need to do anything
there and we'll grab this and we're an
extrude Mt boom nice and we'll grab our
capsule and we'll scoot it in so it's
just kind of touching that as if it's
welded to that point
cool
and then for a little added detail I'll
come in here I will go KL well get those
pieces okay and then we'll also get from
there to like there we'll get those
pieces and we're gonna execute them out
like they're welded to this thing so
I'll grab those grab those same deal and
we'll hit em T and extrude it out just
like up top so it looks like they're
weld it down to this thing
cool and that's taking place on both
sides let's let's get this capsule
symmetrical guys so with the capsule
selected we're gonna hit L and we're
just gonna Center up that access to zero
zero okay once that's done all I have to
do is hold alt drop some symmetry on
there and boom there we go looking good
and looking real good so it looks like
we have some wires coming out the back
here so we can get that going
we'll go it's like both of those well
rather we'll go to our live side just
like both of those solo we'll go top
view and I'm just going to sketch a pipe
in and just for the sake of so it's not
an exact duplicate I'll make another one
on that side and we'll go to let's see
well the spline is way down there huh
weird
move it up
something like that
and there's a lot of points in here so
I'm gonna go spline let's just take this
to natural maybe anyway let's grab a
circle spline will scale it down and
we'll also do the sweep action on this
thing so with both of those selected the
circle and the spline i'ma hold ctrl alt
and that's gonna put both of them inside
of a sweep and you know that hand-drawn
one is just not looking good
that's blind there so I'm gonna I'm
gonna delete it and I'll just do one
that kind of comes out and does its own
thing here and we'll do the same if I
drop that boom under and we'll do the
same over here with that same spline
selected
and I'll just combine these two splines
with right click and we're gonna do that
you should be able to right-click and
just combine both of these
oh it's cuz this thing's in the way
connect objects + delete boom and we'll
set that's a uniform I'm just going to
adjust some of these points here
and inside view do the same
awesome
that looks really good I'm happy with
that
so yeah I chose not to do the cemetry on
that just to give it a bit more a bit
more detail
all right let's let's get these
handlebars real quick so it looks like
they're kind of connected to this frame
here so we'll play off of that we'll
come in here and we'll loop it around
and down okay so it looks it looks like
there's like a few points on this thing
so I'm gonna come in to front view I'm
gonna zoom in here is this front or
technically back it's hard to tell
anyway I'll come in here I'm gonna grab
the spline pen once again and I'm just
gonna make a point where I think this is
connecting to this pipe here so I'll go
like there and we'll come out to this
view here it looks like they come
together at this point but it kind of
comes forward so like like that oh we're
still on that spline let me let me undo
all that stuff okay once again so we're
somewhere in here
boom it comes forward a little bit and
it comes down and forward somewhere like
there and it ends like that I'm guessing
I'm just kind of eyeballing this right
now so this point let's see all these
points they come down and this comes
down even further
and even further
so something like that okay now if we're
gonna we can take this spline and let's
select all those points and make them
hard interpolation points so we know
they're just very linear points now with
the spline selected the type Bezier you
can take it to like B spline or
something or maybe cubic or Okemah you
know and you can really kind of mess
around with these modes here and just
find the look that feels right something
like that this might come up a little
bit more
this this comes down to sit right inside
of that pipe so that's kind of what I'm
seeing right there and we'll do the same
deal we can just copy this circle spline
out with a by holding ctrl and we'll
select both of those hold ctrl alt and
drop it in a sweep and let's make sure
we scale well scale that circle down
geez that's not working
so I feel like the circle should be over
maybe we have to make a new one there we
go that's working so I'm a skill to
circle down a little bit more guys right
about there
I think that's going to be fine
basically something like that
cool so then let's build out this handle
real quick so I'm gonna make this sweep
editable all right come down in here and
we just want to select this bit okay and
we'll hit MT and extrude that out
we'll grab these little end polygons
here and we'll move these out as well
something about there and we just want
to well actually
rather let me um let me hit you why
delete all that weight ul and we'll grab
these points and we'll bring these guys
out so it's more of like an actual
straight handlebar and we'll close this
spline by right-clicking it closed
spline hole and I believe this has some
new options in s22 so you could say
triangles and that doesn't look right at
all select new polygons what does that
select outline
quadrangles maybe we'll just leave it uh
as an gone for now but I'm gonna come
through with KL and I'm gonna make one
two three four five cuts and luckily for
us these cuts are already split up
anyway by holding down shift and let's
hit u L and we want to grab these points
here and I'm gonna bevel these things so
I'm gonna hit em s and let's just bevel
this out the max angle let's see
we want to live update this real-time
update yeah should be on well
that's what I want the offset so we'll
do like 0.25 centimeters
and one point whoa
cool so I want to do that to all these
little sections here and I don't know
yeah it's gonna do everything at once so
I might just have to do it individually
here
point one to five that's number I'm
looking for 0.125 and I feel like
there's a faster better way to do this
in fact I know there is I just don't
know the answer so I want to apply this
yes there we go
apply
and we're going to move this across
symmetrically so we all need to do this
job one time the Phong is definitely off
looks really weird and the Phong what I
mean by that is you can see how the
shading looks off shading looks really
weird so if we go to that sweep and we
take the following angle down to like
was up at 60 angle limit edge breaks
it's not doing anything for some reason
well I think it's fine kind of looks
like a puffy little handle so we'll keep
that
so we'll take this handle and we're
going to copy it on over so I'm holding
alt and we'll drop it into symmetry and
there you go on the other side so they
look a little a little far apart because
we definitely want to drop like a
cylinder in here and connect these
things
so maybe that's something we could have
done is get the shape and the feeling
right of this before making it editable
but I think at the end of the day it's
gonna be alright
yeah that's fine but we just want to
bring these things together so the best
way to do that while we don't have our
spline to edit anymore so one thing we
could do is actually use a soft
selection so I'm gonna grab say like the
handle here and let's be clean with this
I met ul and we'll basically just grab
all this stuff over here
and I'm gonna hit you Y a couple times
and that's going to grow our selection
and it looks like we selected some stuff
up there so I'm quickly just gonna hold
ctrl and deselect all this stuff
so now we should just have these
handlebars selected and I think I'm just
doing this the hard way
want to come in here and just grab this
boom just like that
and I'll hit you well just to clean up
my selection now when you bring up the
move tool you're you're prompted with
the soft selection option I'll enable
that okay so now when I move things and
you bring your radius down to like 20
it'll move things but it'll kind of
bring other parts of the model with it
as you guys can see here it's bringing
some models or some topology that we
don't have selected it's bringing it
with so it's doing it in a weird way so
I think what I want to do is grab more
of this
and then try it
something like that
it still looks a little weird
so maybe the best way to go is to grab
most of this
and do something like that
that looks that looks a little bit
better yeah I'm down for that
we all need to get along in this this
chat here I have to not the boot both
y'all if y'all don't just you know shape
up here we're here to learn guys ain't
no point in spam in the chat that's no
good okay um yeah it'd be nice to like
have a moderator on this chat it's just
me right now guys you know I can only do
so much
but yeah come on guys don't be buts
let's all just learned I can't I can't
read everything that's going on here um
all right so I kind of want to get some
more like wing detail going so I'm not
entirely happy with this but I can spend
more time on this getting the handlebars
right and I know that I need to get this
little handlebar geometry down here
let's spend some time on the wing cuz we
hadn't really done that and the wing you
know it need some help need some love so
let's go to our wing let's grab our
cylinder and it looks like it's beveled
and extruded a couple times down here so
that's what I'll do okay come in here
I'm going to make it edit to bowl okay
go into edge mode and Oh wrong one okay
yeah it striking boom let's zoom in here
may UL and why can I not wait what is
going on
what's happening
some weird mode selected or something no
I don't want that okay I want to bevel
this right so I'm gonna hit MS and I
want to get that nice little bevel in
there so probably something like that
but we'll subdivide it a couple times
why is this not live here we go
yeah something like that and I'm gonna
cut this a couple times with KL
hmm so for some reason I can't see I
can't see this loop path cut Wow what
happened oh I know I said geometry only
okay so I'm gonna cut there and I'll
make some cuts right there and right
about there and I'm just gonna grab this
and extrude it down so we get a bit of
extra detail on the side of that thing
and for the back
maybe what I'll do is just take some
creative Liberty here and add like a
cone or something so I'll have the
cylinder selected hold ctrl and I'll
grab a cone
I'm gonna rotate it back 90 will scale
it way down and I'm hitting s to
actually snap my viewport to the
geometry I have selected and we didn't
rotate it correctly so boom come back
with it like that
yeah we'll just do something like that
and all these updates are happening on
the other side because we have our
symmetry up and running which is exactly
what we need to save as much time as
possible all right so now we have this
added detail on the wing so I think what
I'm going to do is actually hop into top
view here and let's grab our spline tool
and we'll turn on snapping okay and I'm
just gonna draw some geometry here so
we'll start here looks like it comes out
like this
comes up and in goes to about the
halfway point comes down comes down even
more like this comes to the back wing it
looks like it comes
up and out like this back in
and connects here at the end and I'm
gonna just adjust all this stuff
I'll chop snapping
and basically use this and extrude it
cool so I'm gonna hold alt and just
click this little button here and it's
going to extrude all that stuff up it
only needs to be a centimeter it's
probably good and we'll take that we'll
put it in our wing geometry and we want
this to lay flush with the wings so what
I'll do is there's actually a transfer
tool which transfers one object to
another and I don't think I have that is
it up here yes this XYZ little button
you can hit shift C and type transfer
and drag that up as a little button for
you guys so what you'll want to do is
select this extrude wing here and you
can see that the anchor point is way
over here what we want to do is bring
the anchor point more to the center of
this whole thing so we'll hit the axis
Center tool and we'll hit point Center
execute
let's try including the children and all
objects yes so these little buttons here
you want to include the children and
include all objects hit execute and I'll
bring it right to the center and then
we'll transfer we don't want to transfer
let's see we want to transfer to this
wing right here the actual cube
I believe let's see that's huh okay
that's not working let's see what can we
do to get this to work so we want this
transfer okay I think that's because I
wasn't in model mode you need to be in
in mono mode we don't want to transfer
transfer the scale but we do want to
transfer the rotation in a position so
with this little coup P selected I'm
gonna click on the wing and the
important thing is we want the scale or
the rotation to be right and as you guys
can see it looks like we got the
rotation just right enough just perfect
enough to set it in place here and we'll
finish off the last of the detail the
rotational detail and work it in just
like that bring it down now we can slide
it around to make sure if it's just
perfect
so that's your little extra wing detail
right there and you can go even further
on this and inset things and whatnot but
I think that looks pretty good yeah we
got it on on both sides here hmm
so there's a couple other things we can
do we can we definitely need this top
piece okay we need this rope and we need
the the anchors that it's connecting to
all right so what should we do first
here this anchor piece should be pretty
simple let's maybe build the anchor
piece real quick so that to me looks
like just a cube all right we'll scale
that down we'll bring it over here to
the corner right where we want to get it
right there on the corner okay I'm gonna
make this cube editable and we're gonna
scale it to the right proportions
get it right in there basically
something like that yeah and then what
we'll do is bevel these two points here
so I'm hit em s bibble that down
let's take subdivisions two three
boom get it nice and close up here
just nice and close and I think if we
hold control and go to point mode we
should be able to select all the points
and hit you oh oh and it's not doing it
okay maybe we have to select both of
those and we should be able to weld
these one two and then back here I know
it's so close you can switch this if you
hit control D or I'm sorry
if you hit yeah control D you scroll
down and your project settings set the
view clipping to small it'll get rid of
that so you can get get in even closer
and we just want to weld these points as
well boom so that turns to one point
great and then what we can do with this
is use a well actually let's bring it up
wit K L at ul rather I was right the
first time kale for some reason it's not
going all the way around so I'll go into
side view and I'm just gonna make a cut
here so I'm gonna go line cut hold shift
boom there we go and that cut across the
whole thing weird only only one side
[Music]
maybe in that case then to get that
extra line at the bottom I'll grab that
last little piece of geometry and then
I'll hit MT and bevel it out that way we
get that line across the whole whole
thing and then I'll select this side and
this side and we'll bevel that out as
well and with the cube selected we can
hold ctrl make a cylinder
scale it way down this way we have a
cylinder right there right where we want
it beautiful and we're gonna use a
boolean to cut this out so with
bullying's as always a minus B so a is
your your hold this anchor hold that's a
you want to subtract B from it right so
a minus B the order of these matters you
want a on top B on the bottom with both
of those selected we'll hold ctrl alt
and we'll throw it into a bool object
and there you go
looks nice I always do a crate single
object that feels good and let's take
our anchor point and just move it all
the way to the bottom so let's bring
that up point Center we'll just take our
Y to 0 or negative 100 so it's right at
the bottom there and this will also be
inside of a cemetry so we'll hit L to
enable the axis there well zero out the
X and we'll throw that into symmetry and
you should be round the other side
awesome looks good
we have some on the back here some
interesting geometry back here looks
like they're just kind of like thrown in
there on these little cubes right back
in here so I think no one's gonna notice
if we just select this back piece here
spawn a cube on it so we selected the
cemetry we're gonna actually select the
geometry so boom hit the cylinder make
the cube but since the the Anchor Point
was in the middle that's gonna spawn it
right in the middle but it's all good
looks like it's somewhere somewhere
right about there
well gets it right about there
cool there's like some circular detail
in there but we'll get to that a second
that's great let's do it right now we
got a we got a tube holding control
so it's spawning right there we'll
rotate 90
let's take the inner radius up and let's
duplicate this tube holding control I'm
gonna scale it down
let's see rather let's um let's take the
tube let's control C control V or even
once again we'll make sure we have let's
see your the tube selected control drag
it just so it's sitting right in there
and we'll take the inner radius down and
the outer radius down so we get this
kind of look right here and with both of
those tubes selected I'll go to object
check the little fill it box and you get
a nice little fill out there we can
boost the rotational segments to 32 if
you guys would like and take the radius
up just a bit
something like that
and we need to add this little piece on
top so man to me this looks like another
tube rotated and scaled of course we'll
move it up and instead of sixteen
rotational segments we'll do four
rotated 45 degrees I'm holding shift to
snap the angle of degree at which it's
turning we'll scale this up get the
inner radius up a little thinner and
we'll make the tube give it some fill it
will undo that make it editable and
instead of scaling it see when we scale
it it's really crunching these top and
bottom pieces let's just grab the actual
points and move them down a bit
and then I'm gonna grab let's see let's
make some cuts with KL right in the
middle we'll do shift
okay I'm gonna hit ul to select that cut
move it over a bit I'm gonna hold ctrl
right it's right there and actually I
didn't wear control doesn't work
so with KL selected go one we'll go to
and we'll just make sure that we scale
these two cuts on the X so they're just
straight lines yeah it doesn't right
I'll just bring that X slider down to 0%
and then we'll grab these two little
pieces I know it's kind of hard to see
and we'll just scale it down so it's
connected to this thing and finally we
will bevel these edges on the side so
let's do a ul I think we can do these
manually that's 8 should be 8 at least
grab these
so we should have 16 edges selected yep
and if you guys want this little dialog
box you can hit alt V I believe and go
to HUD and just check these little boxes
here total points total edges till the
total polygons and ms2 bevel fantastic
now we just need to duplicate this to
the other side and I'm actually gonna
scale it and I'm gonna crunch it like
this
huh
so I feel like this should be it's in
it's in symmetry
oh it's because I see it's because the
anchor point is not at zero so we need
to select all of these objects here
- the cemetry so one two three four and
we need a group it and make sure that
the Anchor Point is right there at zero
hmm for some reason for some reason it's
not working
weird okay I guess it was in the wrong
Cemetery
sweet okay
so I want to wrap this up with you guys
we will make this little tarp here which
could easily be a dynamic tarp or
dynamic cloth but we won't get into the
into the dynamics of everything
we'll hit these little ropes we'll make
one rope we'll duplicate it across the
way and then I just want to bevel this
front edge with you guys and then we'll
get into the contest winners and this
week's weekly challenge all right so
let's start with um start with the the
bevel okay so I'm actually going to use
a petal bevel modifier I love the bevel
modifiers they really make things easy
and actually if you want to undo a bevel
it's very difficult but was a bevel
modifier you have all the control in the
world so right there I just dropped it
on and you can see it's already doing
its job
I'm gonna go subdivision - that looks
really nice and Melanie thank you for
the super chat really appreciate you yes
I would love the Kombucha sponsorship I
think it'd be incredible
and we're out the cats right now I think
they're sleeping Gilbert's actually back
there yeah he'll come say hi
and yeah for those of you guys who don't
know I do have a print shop and my woman
who does my printing is incredible the
quality is so high and she was actually
out for a while because of the
coronavirus but she is working part-time
now and I still have this 25 percent off
on all prints right now and I know some
of you guys have bought these and taken
advantage of the 25 percent off so I
really appreciate that we're gonna get
those orders sent out to you ASAP the
printer is back up and running but yeah
we got moody shots for days here from
all different countries we got film we
got digital so if you guys want to pick
one up for yourselves
I got like if you click this it's pretty
cool I actually did this in c40 and
octane was make like a little frame kind
of set up to see I'll show you guys what
it would look like if it was framed so
that's just a very easy octane c4d
lighting setup but yeah yeah go ahead
and check out the shop it's noise green
and light calm and get your get your 25%
off on all your prints right now try to
get these prices as low as possible and
free shipping on orders over hundred
bucks Thank You Melanie thank you for
the super chat thanks for the shout
oh it's Ren what's up Ren dude
Ren I hope you're well man I'm looking
forward to that kickflip - I hope you
keep practicing and everyone here in the
chat Ren wants that collaboration
between the two of us to do a little
boss town thing I feel like we'll get it
at some point we'll get it but right now
Ren we're talking about bevel and edges
man that you know there's no such thing
as a 90-degree angle in real life
there's no such thing that's why we're
peddling edges subdivision zero now way
it kind of looks more like a metal like
a chunky metal I like that and we're
gonna copy the bevel modifier over here
and do a Christian with the freaking
kombucha thank you sir appreciate you
with that super chat thank you thank you
thank you hey guys everyone say hey to
Ren wish them well I hope you're
enjoying your Saturday man
all right so we're basically basically
got this thing modeled looking looking
real nice here we've got our edges
beveled that's pretty easy we can get
the wing too why not
you know here let's drag let's find
where are we at here where's this
where's his wing there it is
we'll just drag that that bevel over to
the wing right in there leave and it's
way too intense so we'll just bring it
down a little bit sweet
Renne thanks for hopping into men that's
awesome let's throw that bevel modifier
here as well and we just want to bevel
as much of this as possible
because beveled edges look real real
nice and will do the same to this
extrude
oh nice so I guess in cinema r22
this use angle checkboxes is on by
default which is fantastic because I'm
always checking it if you didn't have
that and be beveling everything edges
that don't need to be beveled they have
no business being beveled in fact let's
get this main cylinder here and we'll
bring the bevel amount down to like 0.25
I know guys I know the the naming system
on this is jacked up it's because I've
been going nonstop you know I've been
going nonstop here on this apologies
apologies to everybody
all right let's get this sweet beveled
well that's looking good point to 5
maybe 0.15 awesome awesome that's gonna
catch the light very nicely same for
this cylinder in here but since it's
still editable we can just check the
fill it's on segments 3 sure and then
point yeah 0.75 maybe for that
and that's the majority of it um maybe
this guy could be the last one here and
then we'll move on to the ropes awesome
I know there's this little issue here
but hey no one's gonna see that I was
gonna see that
perfect perfect
alright let's wrap this out here let's
do let's do the Rope segment so
basically that's going to be a tube or a
Taurus something like that that's gonna
the Rope will actually connect and we'll
use the transfer tool to just bring this
over here right in there we'll go 90
with it and bring it up so the Rope will
be set right in there
okay as you guys can see and then we
have looks like a cylinder definitely a
cylinder so we'll make a cylinder there
and we'll set this to plus y maybe plus
X plus Z yeah plus Z
so this thing is way too bigger now
definitely a scale is down
cool that works okay the length of this
that feels about right to me but the
thickness definitely needs to come down
something like there okay we'll make
this edit the bowl and we're gonna hit
KL and make some cuts here we'll go
probably halfway between that halfway
between that polygon mode selected well
at ul we'll grab these little end bits
here and hit em T to really fill that
out or I'm sorry I extrude that out
that's basically right there that is
your rope and all of this we can pile
into let's let's go one step further
let's take that and just drag it up here
you get fancy with it and do a little
bullying cut in between that but I'm not
gonna go that far right now it looks
like this is rotated around 90 as well
okay let's take those things those three
things
well alt G will group them together and
we're gonna take basically we want this
to pivot from the bottom okay so we'll
go to axis the axis Center tool and
we'll take the Y slider down to the
bottom and that's going to now move that
from that point right
so with this I feel like I feel like we
can probably use symmetry on these guys
so we'll have one here and I'm just
gonna copy call this rope not that it
matters at this point but we'll copy
that control drag over to this point
here we'll move it up rotate it 90 and
get right in there
awesome so we'll take those ropes well
alt G will group those okay and we're
gonna get our anchor point right in the
middle some hit L to enable the Anchor
Point tool or they enable access tool
and we'll get this right in line with
the zero right centered right down the
middle and we'll hold alt and let go on
symmetry and now we have these ropes
just spread across perfectly now the
last thing we have to do is add our tarp
so that's as simple as making a plane
it's a little big so we'll probably come
up with it like this okay and it
definitely needs some thickness to it so
let's make this thing edit the bowl
let's grab all these points might hit em
s so our MT I'm going to extrude it just
a little bit because there's some
thickness on that
I'm going to take these four corners and
bevel them so the quickest way to do
this I'm at ul ru was at UB I think yes
is there's a loop selection there's a
ring selection yeah and then I'll go
into top view and make sure I just
deselect everything that's not in the
corners so we just have those four
corners right and I'll hit em s and
that's going to bevel things just nicely
awesome awesome
and from there we can we can take a
cylinder okay and we're gonna cut a hole
we're gonna cut four holes right and I
want actually I wonder if there's a
cleaner way to do this let me think
about this plane no that's gonna be the
best way so we'll take that cylinder and
we're going to clone the cylinder okay
so if I hold alt and I click this little
button here it's gonna bring up a cloner
and I just want to by - okay and let's
see if we can't just get these guys all
right in the corners their thickness
definitely needs to come down we'll just
say two inches for now
all right and then we'll we'll adjust
this so that it's right in the corners
there that looks about right to me
so we'll use this cloner to cut out
those holes right there right so
remember it's a minus B so with plane
and clone are selected with the plane on
top i'ma hold ctrl shift and throw that
into a boolean object and it looks like
it did its job and made the slice but oh
man our bevel totally or I extrude
totally didn't work so I'm gonna redo
that you will delete those edges there
let's grab everything hit em T and I
think we just need to we need to select
create caps and that will actually give
it thickness
wonderful
so alright with that selected the
bullying selected I'm actually just
gonna hold ctrl to drop everything out
select all of it right click and connect
objects I'll save the original I'll just
call this a tarp dot back then we have
our actual tarp and I know my my
hierarchy is a mess right now I'm just
gonna have I'm just trying to get
through this guy's
we'll take tarp top back make sure it's
hidden so I just had the original okay
and basically what you can do here you
can you can do a cloth stem for this but
I think what I'm gonna do is just make
it keep it nice and easy let's bring it
down we want those four o'clock we want
those four corners and locked we'll
scale it down a little bit I think scale
is fine
let's grab these four middle points are
here one two three four and we're gonna
do the soft selection boom enable soft
selection we'll crank it up something
like that and we definitely want to
bowed out on the top so maybe we take
the point the middle point and instead
of linear let's try
bell or dome yeah I feel like dome is
the one so let's take the radius let's
go like 150
try 175
let's try 150 a little bit and then then
we can come in with that 175 something
like that and definitely at the end of
the day a class name is going to be what
you wanted for this we'll take the
center point access tool scale it down a
little bit move it forward some and then
it's just a matter of rotating these
points to get them right in there in the
center of that thing and I feel like our
tarp definitely needs a little bit of
subdivision
awesome awesome all right so let's bring
it
as we rotate this tarp a little bit
bring it down a little bit and then
we're just gonna start moving these
ropes to get them in place so I'll go
top view here to get that rope centered
up same for this other one up
and we'll look in our side view to see
what's going on here
and this is why I saved a version of
this tarp because I knew I'd probably
want to adjust some stuff because these
holes are I think a little large we'd
want this ring to connect up and around
this thing so yeah not super happy with
the tarp but I think you guys get the
idea I think you can do a cloth cloth
someone that you can actually probably
have these little ropes as splines
dynamic splines and have a really cool
dynamic little system going on here
that's it guys I'll keep working on this
door of the week and I'll post it in the
discord server I'll text her and make it
look real nice but yeah I just love the
stuff I love modeling and texturing and
making things look as real as possible
so guys you don't know I do a weekly
challenge every week on the discord
server and last week's challenge was
spongebob that was the prompt okay so I
would love to go over the challenge
winners with you guys and then also
issue you it challenge yourself so I
would challenge you guys to join the
discord server all right and join this
next weekly challenge because I pick
five best ones and present them here on
the stream talk about them a little bit
so yeah basically yeah that's that's
what it takes when it comes to doing
like hard surface modeling like this
it's just cubes
it's just cylinders to get things and
you built you're building up detail
basically right trying to make things
look as detailed and cool as possible
but you guys saw I started from the most
simplest shape a cube or a cylinder and
I bailed it out things I extruded out
things and got to this point here and
once this thing is textured like I'll
probably go in and add a bit more detail
it's just gonna look really really nice
so yeah let's get to these challenge
winners real quick
we're actually me before I do that just
throw a little quick a little quick what
do you call a guys I'm losing my mind
it's down to the stream you know my mind
gets cobwebby by the end of this thing
let's group all this stuff together I'll
make a material drop it on there let's
do let's crank the index up real nice
let's take the diffuse down
and then let's just give it some
roughness for sure Romeo thank you for
the super chat brother appreciate you
from South Africa dude awesome very very
cool I hope things are cool with you
I hope coronavirus isn't too bad down
there yeah I definitely have some some
work to do here on this on the geometry
they're a little janky yeah I think it's
just a matter of like adding some
surface imperfections to this making it
look real nice and then if we lose our
floor which I'm pretty sure we did yeah
then you should be able to get like
oh we have no hgri that's why oh okay I
see I see let's just change this up
well if we forgot to check the little
box here for mix sky texture so it's
getting the Sun and HDRI to light this
thing it looks real nice
sweet yeah that's just that's just the
detail guys all in the detail okay let's
do the let's do the challenge winners
here so this week's prompt was spongebob
okay
it was difficult once again you know as
always getting really really awesome
submissions to these weekly challenges
and this challenge was very very cool
very different actually very different
from what we've done before this is the
first time we've done
I guess - robot we've done like a
cartoon character so first I'm gonna
talk about a couple runner ups here
because I think they they got really
close it was hard to hard to figure out
the five winners but first up we got Bob
here I think this one's awesome very fun
I like this a lot he's actually doing
something you know he's making some
Krabby Patties but ultimately you know I
had to go some other guys for the winner
because you know you're lacking a
background here you know some beveled
edge here definitely need some of that
but I overall I really liked what you
did
I think the the sponge texture not bad
not bad at all though it could use some
subsurface scattering here maybe there's
a little bit going on there might be a
little bit but I think you did a good
job overall Bob not bad and Tila same
for yourself man like this is really
really good really really close so so
close you can got Gary in there too I
think it's just a matter of like context
you know there's just not really
background but you did get the
expression and same for Bob both you
guys had the expression down which I
thought was awesome yeah and I like the
like the shoe texture and Gary's lien
fun I can see the polygons though a
thing you need to smooth that out a
little bit
I think even inside of his mouth and
carry down here Eric thank you brother
thank you for the super Chad I'm glad
you stopped by
I hope it see you next week and hey give
this give this weekly challenge a try I
think it'll be fun but let's get into
the last mention I just I just want to
mention Willie this is hilarious I
thought this was great maybe laughs in
the best of ways man big fan big fan so
without further ado guys let's get into
these winners here first up we have same
oh this is hilarious I love this so much
it's disgusting totally reminiscent of a
classic spongebob close-up you got this
nasty goop coming out of these holes
here this is horrible so disgusting
really really great job man really great
job Sam Oh congratulations you are a
weekly challenge winner
and one thing I'm doing one new thing
I'm doing moving forward guys is if you
won the challenge last week I'm gonna
replace everything with this week's
challenge winners because you're gonna
have to earn that title back you know
some of you guys are winning these
weekly challenges week after week and
you know you just can't hold them on you
can't hold on to those titles for so
long unless you win every week okay so
if you guys won last week I'm taking
those titles away and for those of you
don't know you do get a a weekly
challenge winner role in the discourse
server and you're put up at the top so
that role will only be available to the
current winners of this current week
okay so if you got it last time it's
gonna update every week so next up same
well congratulations we got seven seven
gunt seven spend gunt
this is awesome like he's totally saying
I'm ready I'm ready
these guys nametag going I like the
lighting that you used I like the
texture that you have going on for the
sponge here it feels fun it's very
vibrant even have some distortion back
here very cool yeah man this is awesome
classic Sponge Bob big fan
congratulations you know you're just
missing you're just missing a little bit
of furniture maybe you know like Maeby's
couch or something back here but hey
that's all good you did a great job
next up Mathis I love this I know that
you know some of you some you guys might
be like oh I cheated he didn't do the
character of it well yeah you didn't do
the face or whatever you didn't need to
this get a little different approach and
that's why I like this a lot
I think the Lighting's really nice and
this is such an awesome moment here I
love this so much moment between two
friends hanging out looking out at the
city I feel like this is kind of the
view when they were flipping on and off
that orb of confusion you know they were
up on that hill it certainly wasn't this
kind of lighting though I like this much
better this feels really cool to me
congratulations Mathis for winning this
week's weekly challenge big fan it but
why not more samples as though you know
you can throw some more samples in here
I'm seeing some green some render grain
here it's it's all good just amp it up a
little bit okay next up we got once
again ice cream paint job going with an
ice cream scene yeah this is awesome
very very very nice and I know that you
weren't the only one to do this ice
cream scene I thought it was the same
render for a second so that one came
very very close to I think it was visual
who did that but yeah ice cream paint
job grats for one of the challenge here
your lighting is incredible your
textures are incredible yeah there's
detail back here there's a motion going
on
there's a scene playing out I think this
is fantastic man you definitely earned
this congratulations ice cream paint job
for one in this week's weekly challenge
and last but not least guys this one
my absolute favorite this guy has not
won a weekly challenge yet
and just blew me away
like I thought this was from the
spongebob movie or something but Zachary
this is incredible this looks so good
the lighting couldn't be better the
colors couldn't be better like your
textures are amazing I love the
spongebob texture here I feel like I can
touch him he feels like a toy you got
the expression down this is just so so
good like I'm about to set this as my
desktop background in fact let's just do
it right now
Oh me this is a fail moment here what is
this okay now it's doing the whole to
screen thing guys
all right look we don't time to
troubleshoot this is just amazing
congratulations Zachary for winning this
one man is just insane so if you guys
want to see all these winners and take a
closer look at them they will be in the
where will they be they'll be on the
disk or server under challenge winners
so take a closer look I post all the
winners up there and you guys all get
the challenge win and roll and the the
challenge for this week what are we
gonna do if it's challenge for this week
let's take a look at the list here let's
see let's see what some of the mods put
out as challenges here let's see
so we modeled something cool today I
usually like to do something that
applies to the lesson so maybe you have
to model something we did robot
[Music]
hmm oh man that's pretty good and these
feelin caricature of your face that's
that's great
bow and arrow noodles alright let's just
say it
ramen noodles that's that's what the the
weekly challenge is this week ramen
noodles okay if you guys want to
participate in this weekly challenge the
subject of your render has to be a bowl
of ramen noodles it doesn't matter if
it's cartoony noodles it doesn't matter
if it looks like it's out of the game
Katamari it doesn't matter if it's photo
real ramen noodles the focus of your
image just has to be ramen noodles
alright you can put whatever you want in
your ramen noodles
it could be just noodles you can have a
little fish cake thing with it you could
have seaweed whatever alright just
however you like your ramen just model
that model that texture that render that
and put it in the weekly let's see we'll
put it in the weekly challenge
submissions that's where you gonna put
it is under submissions I'm gonna make
that live right now we actually did an
overhaul on the discord server to make
things a little bit more efficient make
things a little easier to use
well simpler a little easier on the eye
so check out the new discord server it's
it's tweaked I think it's better I think
it's better so let me know what you guys
think but yeah in the meantime ramen
noodles that is the weekly challenge and
I'll probably see you guys next week
actually I guarantee I'll see you guys
next week
Saturday noon the same time and yeah I'm
gonna just be chilling for the next
three minutes answering any questions
you guys have then I might get out of
here I need some water
yeah how's everybody doing you guys all
good
ah
absolutely guys keep me on my toes keep
me good on the 3d stuff this is really
fun for me and I'm also I said anything
yeah I'm excited I'm excited I think I'm
gonna be doing a sea graph presentation
for max on it'll be a virtual
presentation but it's gonna be really
cool kind of in the vein of that putting
a super realistic photo realistic thing
CG object can be a character it could be
whatever into lie back into a
live-action plate and it's gonna be like
the most streamlined version of that
probably just 55 minutes so yeah that's
in July I think that would be fun um
arias no I did not learn the one-wheel
trick I did not I tried at one point a
while ago but I got close can you change
the challenge no no the challenges has
been selected next week if you don't
like this challenge well I mean that's
the point is a challenge you gotta
challenge yourself you know um ooh how
about modeling or painting one of my
photography shots from the website the
challenge I think that's a good
challenge that's actually really a
challenge we'll do that one maybe next
week I like that
um King if you want to turn your ramen
noodles into a character as long it's a
bowl of ramen noodles if you want put
some googly eyes on it or something that
is totally fine
Daniel yes it can be an animation that's
all good that's above and beyond for
sure but hey if that's what you want to
do all good
do they have the chat as a German I
can't understand you guys that's pretty
cool though
Eric thanks for joining much appreciated
this is always fun for me so yeah I'm
excited to come back next week we've got
a lot of cool stuff I'm working on this
week for corridor stay tuned for that is
there a place where to put Chell and
suggestions there is not a place to put
chalice challenge suggestions right now
unfortunately I feel like general chat
or just a DM on discord is probably fine
for now
yeah guys I'm gonna bounce I'm grab some
lunch thank you again for watching I'll
catch you guys next week
good luck on the ramen noodles challenge
and yeah I think next week I might do
another one of those like render or real
sessions and make something match a
photo as close as possible because that
was a lot of fun that video did really
well too so yeah all right I'll catch
you guys there
good luck have a good day